well hello everyone and I will be not
only your speaker but it will be your
moderator as well due to technical
difficulties and today's live broadcast
will be the practical tips to optimize
surgical results in rodents and we're
delighted that to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lat
roots and sponsored by Ken scientific
Kent scientific is a world leader and
non-invasive blood pressure measuring
equipment for mice and rats for more
information please visit www visit can
scientific and in the booth section or
by a conference line we have a few
important announcements to make before
we begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive so we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green and the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window will try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge this
light window by clicking on the screen
icon and the lower right hand corner of
this light window if you have any
technical problems beyond or here in
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the QA a button which is
green on the Lord left and well I guess
I'm introducing myself i'm mr selfridge
until I'm the university garden area and
director of the laboratory animal
resources center at the university of
texas at san antonio i'm also the
attending veterinarian for the South
Texas accelerated research therapeutics
here in San Antonio and so I guess I
have a Bachelors of Science degree in
animal science and industry and a doctor
veterinary medicine in Kansas State and
i also have
residency and a Masters of Science
degree in libano medicine comparative
medicine and I completed a fellowship
and minimally invasive surgery from
ethicon endo-surgery so let's get
started and it's going to the first
light alrighty we a some of our main
resources although there's many more
than these and as many people like to
use google as resources for rodent
surgery the gutter Caron laboratory
animals is important and to be in to be
confirmed to a good animal care news
program involving rodents and in surgery
a lack international sub tremendous
source if your institution is not a like
accredited well guess what you're
missing out and you're one of those that
are not part of the elite group I would
like to remind you about your
veterinarian which is your key resource
that Varun Aaron must be tapped into
because is a person who really knows
what needs to be known when it comes to
surgery and your animal can use program
solace Yogi Berra said that in theory
there is no difference between theory
and practice but in practice there is so
we all know that we know all the tips
all the key elements of a surgical
program how to maintain an aseptic
program how to do a septic surgery we
know all these things but in reality if
you've done any amount of surgery and
rodents in particular you know that it's
not always what in theory is not always
practical and many times is not it's
often when a person breaks is there a
septic technique but the goal of aseptic
technique should be not
of course would be ideal to be one
hundred percent sterile but that is not
possible really in a practical sense
when it comes to run surgery so the goal
is to really get as close as possible to
that ultimate goal of following sterile
technique and I've seen veterinarians
have seen programs i coax have become
overly overly zealous over perfect
aseptic technique and make life
impossible for investigators that and we
need to understand where the compromises
I'm not going to go into that today but
i just wanted to really discuss that
briefly so let's talk about the wonders
of acclimation all of you or many of you
have ordered the one mouse you order it
from Charles River of Harlan taconic or
Jackson and you know what happens that
mounts the technician goes into the room
and they opens the box or brings the
animal to a biosafety cabinet or maybe
just on the bench the animals placed
into a box the boxes is darkened air
because boxes cover their technician
goes through the hallway and are taking
that box of mice mice are here and all
these new sounds people talking about
how the weather today and you know what
is this who who's documents a new place
and new new new surroundings and the
animals goes into the loading dock and
it is placed into the truck and the
truck is transported your next day they
arrived other destination and then
somebody else it takes him out after
smelling all that diesel and here fill
in all the vibration the animals are
taking out of the the truck taken by
another technician different sounds into
a different hallway new hallway the
animals gone through the animal holding
room place into a new cage and voila new
bedding new surroundings new smells what
do you think that Mouse feels that Mouse
is mighty mighty stressed so what do we
do in this case well my institution
based on published data we have
implemented as 72 hour
period and it has been shown that for
the most part a mice and rats and need
approximately three days to acclimate to
the new surroundings you don't do them
and you start your experiments whether
it's surgical and non-surgical that
mounds that you're working on within
that's only two period of arrival or
less that Mouse is going to have on that
brilliant plan there's going to be just
as large as their heads and it's going
to be stressed and there's going to be
all kinds of confounding you know
confounding result data so let's talk
about this surgeon well at least you
know we know that in the united states
that there's not a requirement to put on
complete sterile gowns the requirement
at least according to the guide is
regarded by the way it's not a
requirement but more like a guidance
document is that we put on sterile
gloves a mask and maybe color heads and
you know sterile instruments and all
that so what do people do well put on
these gowns or lab coats and these lab
coats come in contact with a sterile
field and it's cross-contamination all
them so what do we do on my institution
or at least I do is I make sure at least
I put on these real cheap disposable
plastic sleeves of course I will have a
sterile gloves on a surgical gloves but
I put on these leaves and I miss them
with a high level disinfectant so at
least we're reducing the bacterial load
that could go into a wound should cross
contamination hear it happen so by the
way let me thank love boots the
organizers and all that for allowing me
to participate i'm honored that i'm
participating here and forgot to say
that and i'm very thankful let's talk
about magnification anymore what I do
wrote in surgery I i virtually don't do
any surgery hardly any surgery with some
kind of magnification part of it is a
reflection of my age part of it is that
i can do things a whole lot better with
with magnification you know these little
tools run here i guess i'm using the
wrong box do these you know these loops
right here i have the great for
magnification of course people can use
microscopes and all that and but in
general at minimum i use these surgical
loops i use it 2.5 x and i have a set of
3.5 x and instead of 4.5 x it does no
feasible is not in your budget because
you know they're a little bit costly
well then you could consider just
getting these these sets right here that
you know that ELISA give you a little
magnification and but a minimum I think
people should really get used to working
with some form of magnification here is
a slide in which just a doubling the
magnification makes a huge difference on
how one can work done on the field and
the precision really increases
tremendously magnification on belief is
a must so let's talk about aseptic
technique and infection control so a
services and proteins there is a myth
out there and came from some old
publication a lot of investigators took
up with it that indicated that rules
don't get infections well the fact is
the get infection just like you and I in
any any other animals so let me let's go
this is all about tips today we're not
gonna go into great link to a science
this a lot of this is just based on my
experience now there but I see quite
frequently individuals that really make
their sterile feels so small on the
ground cross-contamination so much
greater here this is what we're doing
some of the dirac procedures here and we
were we'd like to make our table
expander table with with a sterile field
very very expanded so we can place
instruments and all kinds of things in a
way that really minimizes
cross-contamination look a lot of people
will use these
these hot be sterilized as you can see
one here and you can see one here and so
what they do in between surgeries we are
my institution we are up to five animals
per article a set of instruments is that
it will place a bunch of instruments but
these hot be sterilizers and then you
know takes a long time to sterilize and
well why not have to the two is better
than one that way you can distribute
some instruments in and the one on the
left or maintenance and there on the
right hot be sterilizer and you can take
make things happen a lot quicker let's
talk about antibiotic use you must know
that ambiorix may make a third great
surgeon into a second-rate surgeon but
will never make a first-rate surgeon out
of a second-rate surgeon so antibiotics
can be useful but it needs many people
will use and investigators will use it
as a crutch do not follow sterile
technique it's not a substitute for
proper aseptic set the technique it must
be used judiciously because I don't want
to be part of the community that it
develops these resistant strains these
superbugs so it's an ethical issue there
a when if you use antibiotics I would
encourage you to consider antibiotic
rotation to minimize resistant strains
and an institution where I used to work
we used to one Supporter we would use a
one-quarter so passionately another
quarter we use and reflects a scene are
we just rotating to uniform for this
reason I believe that antibiotic you
antibiotics are not recommended and they
need to be justified in that protocol
because if one follows properties of the
technique there is really in general no
need for it it's best when it's used
before the enemy comes yellow meaning
the bug and they should be used
preoperatively I think is much more
effective so you can have the highest
possible levels of antibiotics
add a tissue level by the time that the
insult happens which is really at the
time of the incision and the time of
exposure if antibiotics are going to be
used in general again there except
there's exception to everything that I
say this these lights but once pre-op is
usually all that is needed occasionally
maybe second dose post-op may be
indicated so let's decide when
antibiotics should be used if you have
immune deficient animals and of course
depends on the degree of immune
deficiency maybe I nappy artist maybe
indicating if you are operating in the
lungs and intestines in the stomach and
the maybe in the you know oregon's are
hollow organs well the chances of
contamination increased tremendously
maybe antibiotics might be indicating if
you're doing quite a bit of tissue
dissection the more tissue dissection
want us the greater the chances of
infection so if there's a lot of tissue
dissection they may be antibiotics may
be indicating if there's a lot of old
loss may be important to use antibiotics
if all of us you know if you go through
the gut with your needle inadvertently
well maybe antibiotics may need to be
implemented immediately post op if
you're implanted devices of biomaterials
injected you may need to use antibiotics
if you're implanting catheters for
example jugular catheter well the the
chances of infection increase a
thousandfold approximately and then in
that case antibiotics may be important
at the procedure is very lengthy
obviously the degree of contamination is
directly proportional to the degree of
exposure so maybe antibiotics may be
needed if you have a stressed animal an
animal that is h or ill where their body
defenses are down then
antibiotics and let's not forget about
the experience an experienced surgeon an
individual who really doesn't know how
to do surgery that well that person is
going to create more drama more tissue
dissection it's going to allow the
tissues to disick eight more in that
case maybe until that person becomes
quite experienced the use of antibiotics
may be indicated until the experience is
at such a level that antibiotics may be
discontinued or or minimized so let me
tell you see how the bottom of this line
is this personal opinion please don't
take it as gospel but let me tell you
about my opinion between the use of void
on iodine and chlorhexidine
povidone-iodine mrs. somewhere important
wound pathogens and they have reduce
active in the presence of organic matter
and however chlorhexidine is the
presence of blood does not interfere
with activity so connect city has become
my scrubs my surgical scrub and solution
of choice I conducted an election days
in an institution well-known institution
such as feed a couple years ago we're in
their policy they it was at a hospital
major hospital they had a prohibited the
use of public on iodine as a surgical
scrub so I ask a question why and the
response was that that particular
Hospital a half three documented cases
of post-op infections in their human
patients as a result attributed to the
use of povidone-iodine so again I go to
poor exiting I like it better it's less
irritating and that has become a choice
and we have implemented that as the only
scrub that we use here at my institution
here's an example of an over karate
surgical area you see how it's possible
for the suture material to really go
into the non sterile area if why not
make it more extensive and that way we
can avoid cross contamination issues
draping is important we all know that we
have been told that we need to draper
animals and there are various kinds of
drapes and hear what I see quite
frequently is individuals that the use
that do is there a toxic surgery and
they forget to drape the head I see what
often a more often than I would care to
say so I see individuals that place at
rape right at this level all the way to
the back of the animal including the
tail but they leave the head uncovered
and they do the surgeries were no
covering of any kind I mean it doesn't
take a rocket scientist who realize that
you know nan Chi not covering the non
sterile areas can lead to problems so I
have become a real fan of press and seal
a few years ago maybe about six seven
years ago five six years ago we started
testing this person co-presence eel I
know what a lot of you are thinking that
when a minute I know I've seen that in
the grocery store are you nuts
veterinarian I thought you were a
veterinarian so how are you using that
grocery item to use it as a surgical
drape well you think about this if this
person seal is contaminated look at look
right here on the you see that that's a
steak do you think at this present co
comes contaminating do you think that
this company glad will be a business
today I don't think so so really by
logic person CEO needs to be sterile but
not only that since it's not a
veterinary product i have tested it
numerous times and others have done the
same they have found it to be sterile
every time so we use it because it is it
has a thickness that is appropriate it
is allows me to see the animal it has a
like a sticky surface this surface right
here is sticky and I we put that towards
the animal we also like to include
whenever possible you see the red dashed
circle there like include the tail
because don't forget the details at
thermoregulatory Oregon and that a lot
of you can escape and hypothermia which
I will but they go over a little bit
later it's a serious issue in surgery in
particular in rodents so press n seal
has become a mainstay we use it just for
about everything we also use a present
seal to cover areas a lot of you do solo
surgeries happen to be it happens to be
in my case that I do a lot of most of my
surgeries that have a an assistant but a
lot of investigators will have their
postdocs will do surgery they're on
their own they have to manipulate their
the anesthesia machine as you can see
here or the stereotaxic knobs and you
know see the stereotactic a you know
digital knobs and all that and hey why
not covered them with with some kind of
a cover that is sterile and I users
press and seal for these things to
minimize cross-contamination so when
adjustments have to be made will not
cross contaminated we're not
contaminating our gloves so here's the
same table that you saw earlier more on
the left side and what we did when we do
serial surgeries we will get a whole
roll out which is so cheap and we just
cut sheets after sheets of your she's so
when an area becomes contaminated then
what do we do we just put on a new no
layer of a present CEO and we maintain
our areas very contemporary much
contamination free doing that always
with a sticky side down if you leave the
sticky side up if you leave it up and
then your hands start touching the
sticky side up then it becomes very
frustrating because sticks to your
gloves it sticks to everything so here
we are covering our instruments we're
taking a break just to minimize
contamination you can see here very
easily that there are several layers I
don't know if you can pick up that in
your in your computers there are several
layers because we've done several
surgeries already in this case so every
time we're done with an animal then we
just put some more press and seal and
here we place the animal we're getting
ready to do create a false tendon the
Achilles tendon we're removing the
Achilles tendon up five millimeters of
it and so what we do is that we are in
this case we are and we get another
sheet of a square of person sealed we
make a hole in it and then we place a
foot right through it I'm here notice
that we use a tour prolene or nylon to
kind of elevate the foot after it has
been scrubbed and in that way we really
are isolating the animal from the
surgical field and we also put as you
can see here you can see clearly you can
see this thermometer and the animal they
were monitoring we place a presence here
on top of it and also the person coa
sticky side keeps a thermometer from
from migrating out of the rectum other
ways other ways that we we we can drape
to to kind of keep the animal warm is a
here you can see on the left side you
can see the bubble wrap because it's a
good insulating product and and notice
that we are including the tail because a
lot of he can be lost through the tail
and you make a went on that you can
scrub the animal and then on the right
you see that on top of that we place
another drain
so included there weren't possible there
you go okay let's I think I have a
message here hang on a second guys and
uh make sure that I'm not missing
something or not spoon something up here
okay okay sorry about that I wanted to
make sure that I always got a message
from lab bullets here okay so the fact
is the anesthetics will lead to
hypothermia I'm let me say folks that we
must feel her hypothermia if you are
concerned about your data feared
hypothermia and I'm going to go through
these slides very quickly but I'm just
going to give you a few facts can tell
you why I put why temperature must be
controlled in your surgical animals any
animal there's under anesthesia must
provide a strong source of external heat
they lose won't lose heat very quickly
compared to larger species and the
process starts an induction you can have
a loss of 78 degrees very quickly upon
induction of anesthesia and exacerbated
because we use cold dry gases you know
these are we use the oxygen on makes
with isoflurane and the you know the
coal gas is going to the animal that an
animal's already becoming hypothermic is
worsened because we also shared the
animal we use prep solutions that are
cold and we administrate ministry saline
and fluids a cold so we make the
situation worse folks hypothermia may be
the difference between life and death in
many cases and yeah i know that i have
lost animals especially during my
inexperience years when I was not very
aggressive with providing an external
source of heat
it may be the difference between the
data and that data so we're the most
feared hypothermia because it prolongs a
recovery the animal we want those
animals to come back as soon as possible
they increase the potency of our
volatile anaesthetics that lead to
hypoventilation and when an animal's
under anesthesia when an animal is
recurring they need to get all the
oxygen they can they decrease
hypothermia decreases platelet function
and leads to bradycardia and fatal
arrhythmia and they increase the
viscosity of blood HS I like to
illustrate this with this with this
cartoon run here this picture is that
picture pouring oil well let's say
picture porn water through this strainer
what happens when the water goes through
the strainer that water goes very
rapidly but do the same thing with oil
oil will sort of stick to it it will
move eventually through the holes of the
strainer but will go a lot slower then
water we do this is equivalent to having
an animal whose blood viscosity has
increased because the animals colder and
then gas exchange on that level is lower
equivalent to the oil industry nur so
it's important to maintain the animals
warm feared hypothermia because
hypothermia increases the stress
response to surgery stress is not good
for data I wish I had time to go into it
but they increase the risk of infection
they lead to impaired wound healing and
the latest cns depression and interferes
with drug metabolism and we must be very
careful with particular with these
hairless reads orders or strange like
nudes and neonates that don't have hair
that's where hypothermia it's even a
worsen so what do we do to prevent it
well I showed you a slider but
insulating bubble wrap using press and
seal or even saran wrap sort of the
plastic sort of
traps the heat and and prevent the
animal from becoming excessively
hypothermic I believe that every case
unless it's very very quick anesthesia
that the animals shoot that temperature
should be monitored and cutaneous
warming is very important and also
people use different lamps heating
blankets and and if you're going to be
use a heating lamp be careful you need
to put up their modern thermometer next
on the animal monitor because you can
then the animal in that case and what
about elway heating and warm fluids for
example can scientific as a system and
I'll show you in a minute in which the
gases are pre-warmed before they go into
the animals you can also pull the hoses
that go from the vaporizer and before
the ricci animal why not place those
hoses in a warm water bath to warm up
your fluids I'm sorry warm up your gases
before they enter the animal what about
your prep solutions your if you're going
to use a puppet on iodine or if you're
gonna be using it or exiting hey we're
not pretty pre-heat your solutions and a
microwave so you're not using cold
surgical scrubs what about a heat under
the induction and recovery catch a lot
of people start warming up the animals
right when the animals are the star
surgery but the process really needs to
be started immediately because an animal
can drop 78 degrees easily at the time
of induction then bringing back the
animal to normal thur Mia is more
difficult in that case some people use
hot lures but that's probably more for
recovery animal Nigerian surgery okay so
prevention it should start should start
providing a source of heat immediately
as soon as possible so in an order of
preference of my most favorite to the
least favored is the use of an infrared
homo thermic blanket
a-and the infrared homophobic market i
will show you in a few minutes what it
consists of but it provides a greater
degree of heat than a typical heating
blanket over my thermic blanket will go
to that in the next line okay honey a
thermal blanket and in general what it
means is that a technologist placed in
the rectum and then the blanket the
heating blanket will go up and down
according to the temperature of the
animal doesn't an ideal scenario and
particularly using the infrared homing
thermic blanket the circulating and
blank as you can see in the right is a
one that is most commonly used in nited
states I understand in Europe they tend
to use more the the electric blanket so
there's kind of an argument between the
Europeans and Americans which one is
best so I'm not going to go into that
but and my next favorite will be the
electric blanket which provides a focus
where warmth that you know the butt but
some of those elements because they
focus or warm elements some sources
cover that you know the rest of the
warding and those elements may if the
heating blanket is too high and the
animals there's none interface between
the animal and the heating blanket the
electric heating blanket and a
possibility of burning good can happen
and then my you know last year the heat
lamp is can be quite dangerous it's
difficult to judge the distance so it's
important to have a thermometer next to
the animal of you going to be using it
some institution because I have banned
it because some animals have really been
burned in particular in the postdoc
period that leave the healing infrared
or the heat lamp and plays and the
animals are you know the quadrille a the
proteins their skins and you know the
animals are dead so this right here is
the 10 scientific official sweet that I
have for my institution and this blanket
that you see right here is on the left
on connect there you go right there
it provides cutaneous heating and this
is called that far infrared warming
pants when when using infrared warming
pans infrared light is absorbed by cells
deep within the body of the animal which
safely raise the core body temperature
this way he penetrates deep into the
body compared to other sternal heat
sources this leads to faster recovered
from surgery of course so I love these
things and I'm relief incense addicted
to these Homo thermic blankets in
particularly infrared from that we use
here and let's talk about good
monitoring okay and good anesthesia it's
not just for large species there's a lot
of money a lot of resources already in
place for these animals that you
purchase you have those animals are
expensive not not only because of the
cost of the animal and the shipment and
all that but the time and resources and
and the supplies are using these animals
and plus is a humane way to go so this
sumner street from have this on the
street at my institution also have the
official sweet when can scientific is
great because and the son of sweet a
provides pre-warmed isoflurane gas and
it has the tissue it measures the oxygen
saturation the heart rate the rest
pressure respiration rate and a has a
ventilator and it really leads to better
data the facial sweet does almost the
same in many ways except that does not
provide gas anesthesia unlike as you see
this element right here you see that
right there you can see that as from
this syringe right here from this
arranged here's where the thats arranged
of the art of lorraine is located and
then is it goes
according to your settings it will go
into the animal trail that almost
translucent holes which goes into the
heating element that black little box
that you saw the first line there and
that heating block right there heats up
the gas before it's delivered to the
animals let's talk about oxygen one air
is what twenty one percent oxygen oxygen
I think is a crucial element for the
recovery for the well-being of animals
and animals are anesthetized and so
concurrent administration of oxygen
could really help in the recovery of the
animals and minimize deaths so we
believe that supplemental oxygen would
possible even while the animals are
recovering is is very important one way
not if the only way but one way of doing
it is by using your system like you see
in the picture here and which you don't
turn on the ocean floor and you only
turn on the oxygen now that that way you
can provide instead of twenty one
percent oxygen you can provide a hundred
percent oxygen to the animals hunt be
sterilizers a great for bleeding control
and we this one of those things that
I've learned from an investigator and a
result in minimal tissue necrosis
compared to cholera so you can use this
instead of lottery and in this here
we're doing a construction of rat and
what you do is that you place your
you're a hemostat and hot be sterilizer
and immediately after you can colorize
the spermatic cord and it almost sounds
like the sound of like fajita coming
into into your table if you used to
Mexican food and at least very you can
see in the picture very little tissue
necrosis is great okay so sorry about
these pictures I don't know what
happened that some of the pictures are
not showing like this year done or I
mean they covering someone rewarding but
methods of pain control is very
important pharmacological methods of
pain control that's what this light is
about and who believe that a it is just
like antibiotics it should be used
before the insult happens before pain it
happens and we'll believe also that
multimodal attacking the pain control in
various ways you can see the air on the
palm but doing local anesthesia and oh
by maybe in some cases and some animals
can do spinal and some you know or
systemic and if you're going to be using
systemic analgesics why not use at least
a couple so you can go up to the pain
through different pathways local
anesthesia belief is important and can
reduce the required total dose of
analgesics when you use analgesics
before locally it's a subcutaneously or
in the muscle and before the incision is
made this will prevent the hyperalgesia
which is the amplification of the paint
signor post-op and which is almost like
a non ending cycle the animal there is
pain you know pain leads to more pain to
greater pain to greater pain and so we
use a combination of lidocaine and
bupivacaine and having have fun we
inject on this side the reason for using
this bupivacaine lidocaine combinations
lidocaine works immediately and and it
provides an analgesia right away and the
b-pillar Cain takes longer to work and
but it lasts a lot longer and will help
us like on that and we in this slide
shows for you to download I'm not going
to go into it a day how long lidocaine
is going to last how long it takes to
and work for the second time we're gonna
move on okay so we must not forget
non-pharmacological methods of pain
control we all when we think of pink
otro we automatically think of the drugs
but there is more than just it once
let's talk about that shortly
hey how can we implement from what
non-pharmacological methods of pain
control we can use simple little
techniques and approaches that will lead
to much better pink control which is why
not turn the lights down keep the animal
room quiet and minimizing handlers the
animals all those things all those
stressors that we have in the room over
the handle of the animals a too many
times handling the animals will lead to
greater pain and stress and therefore
pain administer you antibiotic to
analgesic as close as possible to their
indicated therapeutic levels if it is is
when you syndicated every 24 hours got
to stick to it every 12 hours as much as
possible so comfort and a stress-free
environment is which is enrichment will
lead to much better recovery of the
animals I wish I had time to go into
examples I have experienced a number of
times before when an animal is under a
stress free environment or let's say as
as little stress as possible the animals
recover a lot better the animals respond
and the animals will do a whole lot
better don't forget the tasty calories
as a non-pharmacological method of pain
control you want to reverse you want to
reverse a catabolic state that occurs as
a result of the surgery and so why not
provide animals of some high calories of
the floor level I can tell you from my
own experience that what I've heard from
a even investigators are always that I
support that I've seen for example we
these bacon softest I've used them and
these die gels and when the animals are
we coming from anesthesia I'll give you
a good example we do these bone
transplant for one bone to another until
this animals it's very painful
procedures these at these ramps were not
quite able to even stand up and we would
put these die gels and no these bacon
softest on the bottom of the cage and
these animals could barely lift the head
already lapping the dye general so
they're great and they help the animal
be covered a lot quicker social versus
single housing this I get the protocol
investigator said frequently will say
hey I'm going to animals I'm going to
isolate the animals post-op because
they're going to pick at each other's
woman my responses always do you have
evidence the animals are going to go
after each other's wound because
evidence has shown that that a
particular x value has demonstrated
their animals that undergo surgery they
recover faster and they you know they do
a lot better the survival increases when
animals are a at least house mice and
rats are housed with their conspecifics
a post on so to me and investigators
going to have to prove to me that the
animals their particular strengths pics
at each other wounds before allowed to
have those animals is singly housed full
stop I think that concludes my talk that
gives us about 15 minutes for questions
and answers I guess I'm handling my own
QA and let's see first question comes
from rgr girls soccer real donkey from
elpin pharmaceuticals so you would say
that if there are no health factors
three days are enough for randomized to
act let acclimatize to the facility it
is yes the answer is yes and it's based
on a number of publication be glad to
send up to you if you send me an email
and our contagion and that is the case
the next comes from a la parada from UT
ad the question is very very interesting
presentation it was very concise and
definitely useful what antibiotic would
you suggest to use for a high
contamination risk surgery for rodents
my first line of defense is going to be
enrofloxacin baytril the dose are used
views between five and
milligrams per kilogram sub-q next
question comes from Mary wake from Fred
Hutchinson Cancer Center all right Mary
I used to be in Seattle used to be the
u-dub where did my postdoc and let's see
the question is how do you take a piece
of presence CEO of the same role for
successive surgeries maintain the
stability each time well I if you send
me an email I sent you some pictures
because for me to demonstrate it two
words it's very difficult I'll be glad
to send you that those pictures and the
handout that I have Michelle Courtney
Courtney from the scripps research
institute is in their concern that the
president CEO is not sterile to begin
with of course Michelle you that's a
very good that very important
observation it would be but think about
it if it is contaminated do you think
the company that makes presence here
which is glad would be in business today
there will be there will be Adam pistons
for lawsuits because that's used to wrap
food however I'm not gonna I have
because it's a non veterinary product I
have to somehow demonstrate that it is
sterile so I have cultured it many times
a one Supporter we get a batch of them
or we still test them after years we
test them and then we have demonstrated
one hundred percent of the time when we
do a culture that is thorough so no I'm
not concerned anymore because of that
Ruth milano University of Miami what is
your opinion on doing rodent surgeries
in horizontal flow hoods well if you the
horizontal flow hoods what they do is
they tend to protect the animal if
you're using a positive hood and it is
in particular for you to compromise
animals you may want to use that it may
be indicated that something needs to be
evaluated by the I cook but it's also
could constitute an occupational health
issue because you're blown perhaps
allergens and any hazards and into you
and the other concern is that one one
uses these flow hoods where the
horizontal or is there laminar flow hood
is that remember Wilton's become
hypothermic very quickly and by
increasing air velocities on air
exchanges in these systems you are
having an animal's it's the Hat is at a
greater risk of becoming and becoming
hypothermic laura pearson from the
Institute for brain science question can
the bubble-wrap be sterilized yes it can
be sterilized i mean i have not
sterilized it because i'm only using it
to cover the animal but i have you can
sterilize it using the other methods not
autoclave of course is going to melt but
you can if you have the ability to
sterilize items with ethylene oxide then
you can do that the next come from clay
de Silva from the fundus ow home
essential de River all prepped oh okay
good myself I have to worry about the
drop in temperature even in small
surgeries like vasectomies yes I think
so it remember we're we're concerned
about two things we're concerned about
about not only the you know if even if
it's a short procedure we're not we're
concerned about the animals well-being
but we also concern about data so when
an animal becomes even slightly
hypothermic a has to have some effect on
data okay this next question comes from
our get oh sorry oh we see are lost and
lost it okay wait a minute hang on a
second okay argyris sack i used a key
from helping again do you cover the
heating blankets with something or place
the animal directly on them in general I
I have an interface I put something me
too thin not thick but thin otherwise
the animals not going to be warmed up
something to in between the animal and
the blanket and in particular is an
electric blanket more than anything the
next question comes from Moya Holly from
University of Lethbridge okay let's see
what your question is regarding the kin
scientific physiol sweet how do you
protect the heating pad from
contaminations urine feces pathogens the
seams look thick and appear that they
can I saw lots of material and event
that our cover is not used well guess
what I put before I place the animal
under on the Kent scientific physiol
sweet a blanket I cover it with either
with a thin a surgical drape material or
almost always what I use is present
sealed to cover it and keeps it very
clean and of course we in the world
after every surgeries spray with a
disinfectant a son type good question
next question comes from Carolina
marchent from a DG I + D ok hola Marcel
ok I'm gonna have to translate here ok a
hello Catalina nice to hear from you eh
eh ok she just wanted to say thank you
for the presentation and she sent hide
from chile i guess i was in chile last
last year thank you karoliina nice to
hear from you next one is from Alexander
Ellen war rack from Western University
ok so Alexander's questions have you
tried presence e on larger animals such
as rabbits or swine not swine I have
used it in rabbits and the problem with
present CEO is has a limited with so
thus kind of the limiting factor but you
can interpose 10 you know over another
over another and you know kind of extent
extended I've used an reps not in swine
hey I used to do a lot of swine
surgeries and but I haven't done so on
surgery since i started using this is a
study using present see ok the next
question come for Martha Martha
Kristen Cho from Western University
thank you for a very nice presentation
what do you think about the use of
microwave heating pads I've used them
need to be very careful not to overheat
it and also that when you should test
them may be like with this part of your
wrist this is a pretty good sensor if it
is too hard to your race right here then
it might be too hot to the animal the
problem with it is that kind of the
littles heat you know over a period of
time opalina nice to hear from you and
I'm thank you for your work she's a nice
good job Thank You Paulina and the next
question is from animal care technicians
Memorial Hospital and the question is
are there any problems with histamine
released from lidocaine use leading to
pick another surgery site I seem to
remember being warned about this once I
would love to hear that it does not
create the problem okay I'm not gonna I
don't know to be honest because I don't
know there's histamine release there but
what I can tell you is that i have not
had problems and i've used in many many
many times my investigators have used it
to so if it causes a problem it would be
so infrequent that it is worth the risk
of using it in for that very occasional
case is that benefit-risk issue okay
valerie-a Schroeder from University of
Notre Dame hello okay so the questions
can you send me data for the present
seal sterile culture along with a method
to remove multiple sheets if you send me
an email because i don't think i can
remember all these questions send an
email and i'll be more than happy to
send that to you Donna hello Donna from
ethicon nice to see your question Donna
is asking from Attica Linda search from
attic and i should say they are animals
the undergo surgery more likely to
develop by Overton's beyond what they
would have in barrier conditions as I
review my Sentinel rat data what changes
will
concern you not sure Donna I understand
the question hey let me see Hey well oh
yeah I think I understand that if I mean
if you have if you have an animal that
is not in a barrier condition could they
become more contaminated more easily
contaminated oh yes that's not near the
fact that's one of the reasons why is
some people will treat their particular
rules where surgery is conducted they
will treat him with with HEPA filters
with a there is increased circulation of
of air in those rooms and all that I
hope I understood your question if not
we can talk of offline Donna you have
you have my email I know colima dedos
from in situ Inc will the present sealed
melt melt at all become more sticky with
a blanket no it does not but I have to
say that when you put on instruments and
when you put it on surfaces eventually
it kind of releases some of the
stickiness and it becomes annoying yes
that is true but what I can tell you is
that you can use like one of those
glutton four by fours and with alcohol
and you can remove the stickiness yeah
it is one of those things that is
annoying about present seal but you can
just remove it the next question is from
Valerie Schroeder from University of
Notre Dame again what is your experience
with topical lidocaine instead of using
it as a lot local anesthetic injection I
don't think it works as well when you
use it topically on the skin hey it
works a lot faster and it's much more
effective I believe when because it's
even going to be the deeper deeper
layers of tissue when you use it
injectable the next question is from
tirith a Colson for the University of
Cape Town Wow awesome so the question is
I have concerned using plastic wrap
presents seal and chemicals to soak
instruments or prep for surgery with
reproductive surgery that is embryo
transfer and it comes regarding these a
alternate alternatives in this applique
yeah I mustn't suggestions we if we're
using any chemicals of any kind dip the
instruments and all that we always
always always we raise those instruments
with sterile saline with copious amounts
of sterile means in fact or in some
cases we'll just dip the admin the
instruments or whatever it is that your
concern about we will dip them in in
alcohol as well now the the plastic wrap
you talking to the press and seal it's
not going to go into the incision so I
don't think it's an issue but if you
have if you find any problems please
send me a message of love to hear the
next message question comes from
panagiotis papadopoulos with alexandra
fleming very interesting and useful
presentation do you believe that the
time of the surgical procedure has
effect on gestation you an embryo
transfer I did I'm not sure if I can
answer this except by intuition I
believe that the longer the surgical the
procedure it is a greater the degree of
stress and we know one fact that we know
a stress has an effect on embryo
implantation or so I i I'm assuming
they're also has something to do with
embryo transfer so I hope that helps
Sarah hill grill shell from uni map dr.
myself thank you for your presentation
well that's nice of you appreciate you
saying that you're in Brazil right nice
I'm from Venezuela originally the next
question comes from and zero again and
the question is so you would say that
there is no health factors three days
are enough for rats and mice to
acclimatize to the facility well I'm
just basing on the date of the
publications that I've seen now is it
better to acclimatize the animals maybe
five days it's probable problem Raul
that it might be better however
the data that I've read the papers are
not read as shown the atoms become
pretty well stable at by three days in
house now are there strain differences
and things like that probably so you may
have to decide that based on your
particular string Michelle Courtney from
the scripts is it oh no wait a minute
did I did I miss one ok I have lower
pearson from the Institute for brain
science cut the bubble wrap be
sterilized ok that's already been asked
and it can be sterilized will ya answer
that earlier another one from our 0 is
do you cover the heating blanket things
are repeating for some reason okay I
don't know what's happening here ok let
me see if I can just go down because the
question seemed to be repeating here I
have feeling that those are all the
questions a dawn or race Rachel you're
hearing me are there any other questions
that I have not answered okay I think
we've come to the end of the
presentation I'm being told and thank
you for all the questions and before you
we get here let me go to the concluding
remarks we're out of time and but thank
you further your interesting questions
they were really good and for
participating and would also like to
thank can scientific our sponsor for
making today's educational work what
cast possible and but you should know
that this webcast will be available on
demand through august of 2015 you will
be getting an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replays so we invite you
to Ford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
life event and send me any questions if
you want to also privately via email if
you like i love to interact with you and
since we're short of personnel may take
a little while to respond but i will
respond as soon as
I can thank you everyone and you all
have a good day enjoy the rest of the
meeting